Italy is expanding travel restrictions
for the entire country
locking down 60 million people to
contain the corona virus outbreak the
unprecedented move follows another spike
in deaths from the virus despite a
strict quarantine imposed in the north a
ban on public gatherings now applies to
all regions and people would only be
allowed to travel for work or family
emergencies Prime Minister Giuseppe
Conte is urging all citizens to stay at
home now concern over the outbreak sent
stocks plummeting on global markets on
Monday billions were wiped off the value
of major companies key indices in the
u.s. plunge as much as six percent as
trading closed the White House has
confirmed also that the president was on
Air Force One with a congressman who is
now in self quarantine and a cruise ship
that's been forced to stay off the coast
of California has just been allowed to
dock in Oakland a more and more
countries are adopting restrictive
measures to stop the virus from
spreading Israel has become the first
country to enforce a mandatory - we
quarantine for all new arrivals the
decision applies to both citizens and
tourists Victoria getting be reports on
the situation across Europe
Italy's corona virus epidemic already
the second most deadly after China has
taken another dramatic turn with more
than 60 million people the country's
entire population under lockdown from
Tuesday
Prime Minister Zhu Zepa conte says he's
extending restrictions on movement after
another spike in deaths from the corona
virus all public gatherings are banned
and schools and universities closed
until April the third much is there a
pool there will no longer be a red zone
they will no longer be a zone 1 and zone
2 in the country there will only be
Italy a protected zone so across the
whole Peninsula people should avoid all
movement unless they are for three
specific reasons for work emergencies or
health reasons 16 million people in the
north of the country have been under
lockdown since
day riots in two dozen prisons across
the country followed restrictions on
face-to-face visits in modern ER
six inmates died after they broke into
the prison infirmary and overdosed on
stocks of the heroin substitute
methadone as a warning they posted some
posters which say we can only go inside
wearing a mask they're only allowing
visits of one family member at a time
this was a hint of what chaos might
ensue if the virus were to enter the
confines of the prison system it is
almost everywhere else in Italy these
were rare scenes filmed inside a
hospital in the northern town of cremona
and also on lockdown the financial
capital Milan one of the engines of the
economy Europe's major stock markets
from Milan to Frankfurt Paris and London
all suffered dramatic Falls on Monday
with share prices plummeting as the
infection rate soars the economic impact
of the corona virus is already
substantial and will only grow there our
discomforting comparisons being made to
the 2008 financial crisis with concerns
for the preparedness of European banks
and businesses on Tuesday EU leaders
will meet to try to come up with a
unified response but they won't meet
here in person in Brussels with its
steadily growing infection rate instead
they'll be holding a teleconference the
circumstances of this unique crisis
continue to evolve
although not yet into a pandemic says
the World Health Organization in which
transmission of the virus is
uncontrolled now that the virus has a
foothold in so many countries the threat
of a pandemic has become very real but
it would be the first pandemic in
history that could be controlled there
are signs of success against the virus
in China South Korea and Singapore but
not yet in Europe Spain looks set to
launch what's being described as shock
therapy measures possibly following
France
Germany with school closures and
restricted public gatherings these are
moves the government in Britain is not
yet prepared to make keen apparently to
defer the enormous social and economic
costs of fighting the coronavirus but
there will likely be no avoiding them
Victoria Gaytan B al Jazeera all right
let's find out more about the situation
in Italy and speak to Italian journalist
Sabina castle Franco who joins us on
skype from London Sabina thank you for
being with us on al-jazeera this is no
doubt a critical time for Italy the red
zone being extended to the rest of the
country now how exactly are they going
to enforce this well they're going to
enforce it with the police authorities
of course and everybody who's moving
around will be asked for what reason
they're moving around and they can only
move around because this decree
effectively is called you must stay home
so if you do move around you need to
have a valid reason for doing so either
you're going to work or there is some
sort of an emergency or it is for health
reasons so you just can't leave the home
for any reason or to go out and have fun
in addition of course the Prime Minister
has extended the closure of bars and
restaurants not only in the north of
Italy and you know from until 6 p.m. but
now it's across the whole country so
there's not going to be much to do after
6 p.m. anywhere in the country because
there will be nowhere to go our discos
will be closed
pubs will be closed gyms are being
closed there is also going to be no more
sporting events in the country at least
until April 3rd and of course all
schools and universities will also be
closed initially now until April 3rd and
then we shall have to see whether this
will be extended or what will happen
after that yeah and so how are people
Savina coping with these restrictions
and have they accepted that life is
going to change for them well I think a
lot of people
very frustrated because they it's going
to be very complicated for families not
everybody lives in the same place many
people are being separated of course the
Prime Minister has said that the
transport in cities will be unchanged so
people will be able to get to work if
they have to using public transport but
what we will be seeing is what we've
been seeing in the north of the country
until now basically empty cities empty
bars empty streets and no one in in
shops except if it's absolutely
unavoidable basically if you're going to
buy food and people that are keeping you
know at least a meter apart from
everybody else the restaurants and bars
have also organised themselves so that
you can sit at a table and be one meter
apart from someone else in addition of
course the government has on television
constantly these videos explaining how
you should be behaving washing your
hands wearing surgical masks not
sneezing in front of somebody but using
tissues that are disposable so the
country is really having to adopt a
completely different a new way
unprecedented let's say way of living
indeed
thank you very much Sabina for speaking
to us about this arena castle Franco an
Italian journalist joining us there from
London